[Music]
how how do you lose your virginity
uh i was 19. i'm so glad the teen came
yeah i was nine i was
um i was nine i was living in a problem
where don draper was raised
and um
[Music]
i was like yeah yeah
a lady hobo yeah oh
what a dream yeah she had experiences in
that bindle yeah she made me use a can
of beans as a condom
nick i don't care how it's doing that is
the funniest thing i've heard all day
a lady hobo made me use a can of beans
as a condom and about a hundred people
were like we'll get the next one
that is absurd thank you so you were 19
yeah uh it was uh it ended up being
valentine's day oh uh by chance it was
president's day weekend which happened
to be
turned into valentine's day okay with a
friend with a friend
uh all she was also a virgin
um
and you just made a pact to get it out
of the way no we just it just sort of or
get it was like one of the few real
experiences that felt like a like a sort
of storybook uh kind of like oh like
we're both virgins and we didn't know we
were gonna hook up tonight and we're
let's so let's have sex uh and she
pressed charges
uh it's like a bob seger song yeah yeah
just got caught in the rain yeah yeah
kind of and warmed up uh yeah and um
warmed up it was real fun and then uh
is it weird that it was in my sister's
bed
is that true yeah how many
do you think i would just propose that
as like a hypothetical
tell
tell me about a couple questions how
many stuffed animals are on the
comforter
no she was older than me i didn't have
sex i didn't lose my virginity in a
child's bed
because that would be weird yeah were
there any photos of your sister kind of
like on the bed stand just one taped to
the face of the girl i was losing them
[Applause]
i'm gonna use every ounce of my pulse to
make sure that this part stays in the
interview
[Music]